[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
sleep
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
what's going on you guys
gaming out of here lord added coming at
you with another attic show where we
talk about the past
present future of gaming i got dirk
griggity and big cloud gaming what's
going on guys what what you guys been
playing here recently man
what's up man
how you going big clap
all right so uh
i've been on horizon uh lately been
catching up on my backlog finished some
games that's what i've been playing
and uh also yo it shows the craziest
time for his camera freeze look at him
you know someone screenshot that before
it goes away it froze
when they're my friend oh i did when you
see the last there you go i was about to
i i was about to start like beaming it
when you see the last of us remake
anyway
last
okay so horizon and then i gotta look at
my camera i've been playing horizon
finish that up uh what not playing my um
my backlog finishing all these games up
also um playing master duo on pc that's
what i've been pretty much playing and
uh yeah having fun
what you've been doing dirt
come on playing that whale collection
yeah i actually have i i've played a
little bit of that last night also been
playing as does falls and i downloaded
straight so i'm looking forward to
checking that out after the podcast man
so you know i'm interested in that game
um so yeah that's about it man
yeah as a cat man jumping around look
look i ain't gonna say that straight
gonna be a good game
but what is appealing on walking around
as a cat like someone explain this to me
please
oh
no i don't know i didn't i don't want to
uh oh i wanted someone to explain to me
what was the feeling about playing
you mad cause that character got nine
lives you only got one on your xbox
that's what you're trying to say that
what you're trying to say look it's
gonna have to have nine lives because it
looks nine lives worth of boredom i'm
gonna be real with you like
i saw i saw someone playing and they're
like like walking through a library and
i'm just like
what
artistically it looks good uh it looks
really good i mean i i didn't really
keep it real if this was
a game that isn't about a cat it
wouldn't be getting this much attention
you think that's it that's right i think
that's it like i i don't think we get a
lot of
games about animals like that like
that like most of them they have like
super hot superpowers or something like
like you literally walking around as a
cat
i i can't make this stuff up and people
are eating this up man they're eating
this up
and then i'm surprised too i was
surprised by the critical acclaim it was
getting it's got a lot of high praise
which is
shocking
yeah so yeah so i'm gonna give it a
chance you know i'm gonna i'm gonna take
it out when i get the chance to so i
i've been playing as dust falls this
week i don't know did any of you try
that out it's it's on game pass yeah
great story so far you know and
i like those types of games you guys
just finished the quarry so i'm
definitely loving this so far
yeah so what about you [ __ ] cloud uh or
are you over there playing as a cat
neither sure neither yeah didn't play
neither
so uh
that's so like when it comes to dust
balls like i i will say that it is a
pretty unique game
there are aspects to that game that i
haven't seen in other type of
point-and-click games what's funny is i
said in my review i compared point and
click games to something like the
walking dead
life is strange some dude
came with me with the the longest
paragraph in those comments sections
saying you know what man
we you know what we gonna do we gonna
read this comment live
cause i didn't say now look look if you
in the if you were in the chat
this is some dumb stuff you said man but
you know it is what it is yeah i i get
it you know if that's what you feel i
personally feel like this
this isn't the right thing so keep in
mind i i compared it to like the walking
dead life is strange and he said
point-and-click isn't accurate for
uh life is stranger uh the walking dead
i get you meant choice based games where
the little gameplay beyond walking but
point click's a specific turn to not get
it confused hopefully most will
understand what you meant
i'm kind of confused like would you guys
consider the walking dead
you know um what's that uh
what's that game fire watch fire watch
uh life is strange i feel like those are
point-and-clicks
like oh [ __ ]
in life is strange in the walk of dead
you could walk a little bit
yeah yeah
for a couple seconds yeah you can't go
far though in the game it's it's like
locked you know i mean like it's not
open it's absolutely i agree yeah so you
know i'm not saying that the individual
maybe he's right technically maybe that
is a different genre but to me they are
the point clicks they all the point
clicks yeah you know i agree with you
well
i'm sorry even super massive games are
like point and clicks kind of you know i
mean you know you walk around a little
bit you're still kind of point and click
yeah yeah your master just has like a
bigger budget kind of like uh detroit or
david uh cage yeah games that finally
dream like
you know like um heavy rain et cetera
like there's
how far you can go but again there's a
budget there's a style to it that's all
of us
yeah
so it is what it is you know i did enjoy
it uh i think you know for those of you
that want my uh detailed perspective on
it i do have a review out on the channel
as dust falls uh you know i don't
here it is when i do reviews i don't
tell people a number i don't give a one
through ten nomadic number it's pretty
much like at the end give you my
opinions about it and you take that
those opinions and decide if you want to
buy it yourself i feel like too many
numbers on these reviews are weaponized
so i i don't do it but if i were to give
it like a number it'd probably be like a
seven eight out of ten you know i i i
don't think it i think it
uniquely aspect that is done that isn't
in other these point-and-click type of
games but i don't think it's anything
like crazy special you know what i'm
saying but what i will say is like the
outcomes of this game i will
the replayability i ain't going to go
back and play because i'm not that kind
of person but i can understand
people
would go back and play this like
what happens at the end of every chapter
it gives you like pretty much like a
tree branch
it shows you what this could have went
this goes different paths yeah and once
you get to the end of the game you know
like you know the outer worlds you beat
the outer worlds tells you stories on
how everyone's like what happened to
them well it kind of has that in this
and you could see oh this person had
five different endings to their story so
i do see this game having a lot of
replayability and you know if you want
to get like you know a significant other
or girlfriend or something into
uh you know this type of game then i do
feel like this would be a good game to
to open up to because you know there is
fighting man because out goes is like
you got your typical we got a couple
seconds to choose and if people choose
different things and there's not a
majority like i choose one they choose
the other it will pick one of them
random but then you got these places in
the game where
you have to agree
like there's no majority thing like
there'll be like three options and you
all have to agree on one option so you
will fight until you figure that out and
i like that because i think that's a
good perspective of the game but let's
say we can't agree on something it's
called override system where i can
override their
choices and make the story go my way but
then they can use their overrides to
override my override now i don't know if
you could do it three times but you know
that's a little bit logistics on the
game man so we gotta first off
i'm sure some of you noticed hustle
isn't here
uh hustle has decided he wants to take a
little break from the podcast
uh you know
hope hustle for uh the uh the bright
future man he's a great dude uh but you
know right now we're gonna uh have big
cloud in here to uh you know take his
place
uh see you i hope it's like i said
at the end of the day you know
i don't even think it was like creative
differences or something like that you
know hustle just wanted to focus on his
own content and stuff and you know my
hat's off to him and i hope him the best
future and you know that's pretty much
all we're going to speak on that i want
to think there's like some beef every
time someone like leaves a podcast
people think that's beef they assume
like people think oh man there's about
to be a dis track record first off i
don't i don't create music so i couldn't
distract anyone so you can like everyone
in this podcast could leave my stuff
five or six times and i couldn't
distract any of them cause i can't do
that i don't i don't have the skills to
do that
uh but you know like i said wish i
showed the best well definitely go over
there and follow him on twitter and
stuff uh but you know we're gonna go
ahead and get on to the uh to the show
man
we got the last of us remake situation
that we're gonna talk about i'm sure big
cloud is gonna love that one we got xbox
and disco
and we got xbox and the activision deal
may be ending here soon maybe we'll get
some information on that here in the
next month month and a half so what do
you guys want to start man what you guys
want to start you know you know what i
ain't asking you we start with the last
of a situation that's what we start with
so for those of you
that don't know what's going on with the
last of us you know i always assumed
that's just me since they named it from
the last of us to the last of us part
one
that they were gonna like
brawl back the gameplay a little bit to
to mimic more of the last of us part two
now i know that was
all speculations
and i know that the leak that we're
saying is speculation uh but you know
for the most part
up until now it's been looking like
they're charging you full retail price
for just
an up-res version of the game that has
better uh you know better textures
better pop-ins like it the game does
look drastically different don't let
people tell you this game doesn't look
different than the uh the xbox one
version not the xbox one the ps4 version
ps4 uh so
that's not one version yeah yeah you get
what i'm saying man so
what i want to talk about is this leak
that happened that said that apparently
the game's out in the wild uh keep in
mind that this game went gold a couple
weeks after it was an uh after that
little thing happened with the release
date
so that's kind of curious that they
didn't show gameplay with a game that's
going gold
why didn't you show the gameplay so that
makes me kind of think the leak is real
because i do feel like we're at a point
where we know what the game is why are
you hiding the gameplay
yeah uh because it's it's i wouldn't say
i don't think it's like false
advertising anything that it's like
strategic advertising you know it's a
bad income so you don't want to show
that
version of the guys too though i mean
it's not like we haven't seen this game
already we played it twice you know i
mean ps4 and three so
you would think that would be like one
of the big highlights you show off like
i don't know a dodge mechanic or the pro
mechanic if that is going to be added
in this
um
it's one of those things you're just
like okay
uh
sony i would like you to be a little bit
more transparent with this and then you
got people going oh well read the blog
yeah i read the blog the blog said it
was going to have updates the blog said
it was going to be using haptics and
everything you know everything that you
would expect to go with that 70 dollar
price tag but
nothing that confirms you're actually
going to have new mechanics such as
prone
such as dodge or the wii feature
whatever you want to call it um they did
say that when you change or upgrade your
guns that it happens dynamically like it
does in lassos 2 that you can fabricate
whatever parts so that is going to be
incorporated in the game so that's cool
so that gives me a little hope that you
will see the stuff in here but at the
same time it is worth noting to be a
little mindful
um of what you're getting yourself into
and keep in mind too it's not like it's
forty dollars
this is seventy dollars this is the full
retail uh price and it doesn't come with
fashions and i remember i said this when
we when it first revealed and dude's
like oh who needs that we got facts
coming out next year i'm like we're
talking about overall value here and we
don't even have a set release date for
when they're going to reveal the
multiplayer for factions too next year
it makes sense to have factions to tie
you over that way you can get more in
tune with the game know what you're
getting yourself into and then go into
facts just to use multiplayer which is
going to be its own separate thing but i
digress
that's just how the internet is
yeah actually that that's a fair some uh
analysis of the situation
uh i will say that when it comes to
something like this it just
it seems a little shady marketing to me
like like like i said strategic
marketing where
uh you know the outcome is going to be
negative towards you you don't want to
come out openly and say that you kind of
want people to either wait to the last
minute to to open up this type of game
or
they're finding out when they're playing
the game
because they are offering
you a game that was released in
years ago and they're offering it to you
with half the game if you want to
consider like the multiplayer the other
half of the game
and there so one would think that the
price would be lower and not to mention
since it's
the most there's no multiplayer in it
it's an old game too one
sometimes when these type of games are
remade
they come back at a fraction of the cost
like 40 30 40 dollars and not only is
they did they re they they remade half
of the game
but they brought it back to a point
where it's just like
they renamed the name for some reason
and now people are at straight up you
know tagging audi dog asking them is
this true or we're not going to have
these these uh you know these new
mechanics in the game that's what's in
the last of us part two and naughty
dog's not responding so i mean what are
you doing they got to have you seen the
replies like dudes are flat out saying
listen if it doesn't have xyz i'm not
buying this game they're flat out
telling you on twitter wow yeah and
people are saying that on twitter so
listen man it's a slippery slope
it's been nice man you have to be very
careful how you tread on that are you
not going to incorporate this stuff is
it going to be incorporated if it is
now is the time to say yes or no
now it's time
how do you feel about this dirt is this
something that you even care about like
i know you know we've talked about the
last of us and i know you've seen
interested but i don't think i've ever
got simply if you're gonna buy this game
what's your thought process in this
whole situation with the last of us part
one
first off let me say that i love the
last of us i bought it for the ps3 i
bought it for the ps4
excuse me did you platinum though no
i just played and even though xbox one
platinum nothing well 100 nothing uh no
so i didn't platinum anything but i love
the uh the game
am i going to buy it i have to be honest
no
um unless it shows that there are some
big improvements besides graphically
because obviously it looks better
than the uh original ps3 and the ps4
remastered
so i'm just kind of like
in a wait and see mode
if they're going to show some type of
gameplay because the game is set to
release september or something right
ninth september 9th yeah yeah
so that's still a couple months away um
if they're going to show some actual
gameplay before then
that's kind of the mode i'm in uh so we
don't know if this leak is absolutely
true
possibly
see like big cloud said you know a lot
of people were
um asking all your dog questions online
they really haven't responded yet and
some people are kind of like look man if
this stuff isn't this is true i don't
know if i'm going to buy the game so
that's this so this is an interesting
topic
but me personally i'm more than just
waiting to see mo
because i'm not going to say i'm super
excited for the game even though i love
the franchise but like we like i just
said you know
there's not going to be anything new as
far story wise
um so
i'm just going to sit back and wait man
and wait to see
what happens
yeah
there might be like abby scenes at the
end or something like that just to
continue to continuity at the end of it
and you might see like the doctor change
you know i'm not like out of here yeah
yeah yeah
they might do that but i don't really i
can't piece together anything that would
absolutely add to this because left
behind is already confirmed to be in
this so i finished that already too on
the ps3 there yeah so you're getting
left behind you're getting the base
model games i'm just like okay that's
cool that's great game looks great but
come on sony come on night worse
fashions that would have shut up so many
people i'm telling you people but okay
i'm getting all this we've got this too
you know all maps all weapons you think
anybody would complain no you get the
full package that'll be worth it yeah
now it's just like no you're that's
ripped from the game and they pull the
last of us too legit remember last of us
two didn't have patches right so my
question to you guys is
if faction comes out and it's a free to
play that's okay but once a faction
comes out and it's like 30 bucks
i mean that's going to be that's not
really it's kind of destroyed because
it's a different story but i feel like
it makes the last of us part one even
look worse like they wanted you to pay
60 70 bucks for the last of us part one
two they want you to pay 60 70 bucks for
the last of us part two uh two and they
want you to pay 30 bucks for factions
which in all sense of reality that game
mode should have been in all those games
that i just mentioned well
see but i was getting ready to save um
but what made them look crazy and shady
is if that does happen right like
factors does get revealed let's say it's
free to play or it does have um price
tag on it and then they come out with a
bundle with that came and lasted what's
what you said i'm saying yeah the
ultimate experience then i would say
that would be like the ultimate shady
thing i've ever seen but uh fascist too
for what we remember is going to be its
own separate like yeah that's not a game
yeah it's a game by itself it's in a
different like area it's different
characters so they're doing something
fully ambitious i'm expecting something
totally new with the new factions uh
yeah if they call it 70. i hope it's not
saying yeah who knows yeah i hope it's
not so
but i'm just expecting something totally
new it seems like they're obviously
they're building in front of ground up
they've been working on it for
a couple years um so i'm expecting the
new multiplayer
to be just something totally different
something bigger
than the previous factions you know
that's what i'm expecting and will it be
free to play who knows uh who knows but
i'm expecting it to be a big deal yeah i
could see it being free to play and open
the pc just with sony's new perk uh
focus on pc gaming they just dropped
those new headsets in those monitors
they're pretty much prepping everybody
listen
the next step
if you want if you want that option it's
pc and you're getting this and i don't
know if y'all saw yeah i paid this to
this new spider-man uh trailer that they
did for insomniac yeah pc you seen it
yeah they were like really saying you're
listening this is the true ultimate
experience yeah yeah yeah i thought
somebody stopped playing around they're
like listen you want the true ultimate
experience animal console it's on pc
that's why they just dropped these
monitors for you i'm telling you they
know what they're doing yeah they knew
man i'm gonna not listen they want to go
day and date or blah blah blah it's not
happening i'm like listen i'd be shocked
by the end of this generation we don't
see day and date of some sort whether it
be multiplayer or single player
multiplayer makes more sense though uh
if we're
being more strategic uh still having the
live service games uh the 10 that's
going to be in development yesterday
right so
we'll see man let's see
you know [ __ ] i agree with you because
think about the last of us part one when
they announced it
they announced it was coming to pc not
the same day but they already announced
it is coming to pc so
the future i think is pretty obvious and
and i have so many kudos for it because
they're like look man this
this industry is evolving and we have to
evolve with it yeah like sony sony
doesn't want to be in that predicament
where
it's literally just playstation you know
i mean and that's the only thing they
gotta rely on then they gotta rely then
they gotta worry about meeting deadlines
because y'all remember ps3
tell lies was even tougher to make for
that because there's so much on them
developers they they talk about that
like it's the horror stories now they're
on cloud nine they can pretty much you
know they're selling like hotcakes
they're guaranteed to sell it makes more
logical sense just to really take
advantage of that and when you have
stuff like the mcu
really pushing your brand at this point
with spider-man by itself
yeah i mean logically it's just like
listen you wanna you wanna branch out
that's why
that conference or that little uh yeah
that conference that um
jim had where he was talking about uh
playstation beyond the box when you saw
the equals it's very similar to xbox
where it's you know playstation's the
center point then you got mobile you got
console
uh pc all that junk like that's what
they're doing they know what they're
doing and people just don't want to
accept it but listen it's going to
happen so
prepare to change your content at some
point it's going to happen i don't know
why people keep fighting this like oh
it's not going to happen it's bad enough
dude you're saying pc's not a platform
listen it's it ain't that deep
hey you know what it's it's not because
i remember vividly in 2016.
there were some xbox guys that lost
their mind when xbox announced yo their
games you know our games are going to pc
day one some people lost their minds
xbox guys got over it me personally i
never care i play on console that's all
i care about just continue to put the
games on console so some of the
playstation guys that still you know
kind of upset because playstation are
putting their stuff on pc trust me
brother you can still play it on your
ps5 nothing's going to change it's just
it's going to be on pc who cares man i
mean that's how i feel it's a rap at
that point and um you know dude jack
like i'm going to jump the pc here's the
thing they don't care exactly they got
you covered by the game just go ahead
and go there and you know what's funny
people will say that stuff like that i'm
gonna jump to pc and play their games
over there they're still on console they
they make more money off that game than
they do off selling you that playstation
yeah it is what it is you know when it
comes to me in this situation
um i do feel like it's a little sketchy
i do feel like
you know that factions the reason i
brought up the factions in that kind of
scenarios because i do feel like there
should have been a factions in last of
us part two there should have been a
factions in this remake and then the
branded out factions they're doing now
uh you know that should happen because
the difference between
the last of us part two and now is we
kind of felt like you know all right
we're getting the last of us part two
factions but it's gonna be a later kind
of thing you know what i'm saying uh but
now it looks like it was a a completely
new experience so that on that side note
is it's like
were they even having this on the table
back then
like what was this even in development
at that time or
because they got the backlash that they
got it did they put it in development at
that time um
that's the question this is the question
i only had two though um
you got to think about these leaks man
the leaks by itself pretty much killed
last was part two before they did
it pretty much killed it like once the
story leaked all the crazy twists and
turns got leaked it did a lot of people
were turned away from last week's part
two i was surprised that it sold
around what 10 million i think that's
what they said it was like
same same as goes to shima now mind you
goshichima was brand spanking new ip
yeah
this did 10 million and this was the
sequel to one of their biggest selling
games period last was one they didn't do
much much so
i don't know man it's it's weird it's a
weird situation now does that excuse us
not having factions in this game no and
anybody making excuses saying oh we
don't need it you're out your mind
you should you should be the main ones
that yo we need that because ain't
nobody playing on that ps4 version
nobody wants to go back and play that
ps4 version we want the new up to date
one you know i mean with these people
with the ps5 no load times i would take
that any day of the week over what we
got with the ps4 factions
but
you know you know how people are man
forever for everybody who speaks logical
there's always that one
that ain't gonna say this we'll go ahead
and move on a little bit to the factions
uh you know specifically
uh now obviously we know stuff's going
on with the factions we know that it's
in development we know it's probably
going to come out sometime next year
um
are you guys a little worried that it's
most likely going to have that free to
play model and maybe you know because i
know a lot of people was upset with the
way that they handled the factions and
last of us not like of the factions and
uncharted 4
in these factions gamepl it is a
free-to-play model the only fear that i
would have for that is them putting
weapons behind that like they did in
fact one i don't know if you all
remember like the crossbow and all that
stuff all that stuff kind of broke the
game because it added new mechanics like
bleed and stuff like that i don't think
weapons should be locked behind a
paywall so if anything
make it cosmetic yeah yeah yeah yeah
go all out you know kind of like do it
like you know rocket league guy right
how rocky league was free to play and
then it like really blew up you know
which mostly cosmetic stuff you can buy
and whatnot do that and if you need to
then you can add other stuff down the
road like for example you being able to
play as joel or l or something like that
you can sell characters if you want to
you know really push the customs age
kind of like call of duty ronnie put
those legacy characters in the game you
can buy a legacy card you can play as
like makarov or something like that you
can do something like that they had
rambo one time too didn't it yeah
rambo yeah you can play as legacy
characters or characters from other
games why not throw um
legacy naughty dog characters in their
own pages nathan drake yeah yeah you
thought nathan drake you know jack and
daxter why not be creative with this
multiplayer and um yeah i could
definitely i'll definitely get mine
enough
i think if it's free to play i think
that's a given that they're going to
have uh you know some type of micro
transactions and i don't listen i'm the
type i don't have a problem with micro
transactions as long as it's not paid to
win i just don't care man you know even
if a game
is full price
listen what other people spend their
money on is their prerogative i can care
less as long as it's not paid to win
that's just how i feel about it so if
this game is going to be a free-to-play
game which is definitely possible yes
i'm i'm fully expecting um some type of
monetization with the game absolutely
yeah i hope they don't add perks as well
now they damn i just now i thought about
that they put weapons and they put perks
behind the paywall in the original
faction yeah i heard this like you can
heal faster move faster
nah i don't remember that but while they
did all that yeah there was there was a
few perks you can move faster and crouch
like that that that's behind the p wall
it's a few so
yeah even yeah yeah that that right
there now that's paid to win right there
yeah yeah you don't want that yeah you
don't definitely don't i
i've mentioned it before like i'm a big
fan of the way destiny does their micro
transactions where you know you can't
you can't necessarily get a lot of the
stuff
that is current
but
you can get a lot of the past stuff so
like for instance like season passes
you in season two
you could buy the new season two stuff
but they have an in-game currency that
you can get the season one stuff slowly
because they're like they'll like pretty
much
like roll it out to you in small groups
like here's two here's one
you know there's a new emote that you
might be able to get that's the way i
would prefer cosmetics because
especially if you're buying a game you
know and a lot of these games slowly
rotate from a paid model to a free to
play model
i do feel like
there are a huge amount of people that
aren't going to be able to really invest
a whole lot into the game financially so
to keep them people playing make them
play longer let them have access to the
same stuff eventually
uh because
in my opinion the wells are going to buy
this stuff regardless if they can get
them eventually they don't want to wait
for them they want to get them now
because they like what they see now
it's an it's it's at that point it's um
it's an impulse buy
and i don't think just because a well
knows that they can get it six months
from now is gonna stop them from buying
it then
yep uh i think they're still gonna buy
and that that's the only thing that i i
hope they do is they have a little bit
more of an equal thing when it comes to
stuff like that uh i can't stand when
developers get too greedy with
everything free to play like it's like
look man like reward people for playing
your game just as maybe not just as much
because they they're they're keeping the
bills on realistically then the people
giving you money for cosmetics but
reward the people playing your game too
like don't don't forget one over the
other but you know
let's move on to xbox
and discord uh discord i woke up this
morning you know first off people ask me
attic why don't you put up the um
uh the pre
link before the podcast starts because
usually i do it the night before the
morning of
but little birdie told me yesterday not
not to
said i'd have something to talk about
today so
uh i was all right so i didn't put it up
i went to sleep and when i woke up
huge news discord and xbox have a
partnership
uh so and not only is this a partnership
this isn't some we're just gonna put the
app on your store and if they want to
download it they can go look at like the
the posts and stuff this is a full
integration to the xbox ecosystem
where you can actually join discord
calls
like you naturally would an xbox live
party and i think
yeah that's big that's huge yeah uh so
you know what we're we're going to let
big kai go last because he's a
playstation 2. you know he
dirt gets royalty on the xbox topic
what was your thought process when you
saw this dirt and you know
do you i know
is this something that even applies to
you because i do feel like a lot of xbox
people
they're not going to really care too
much of this because they play on xbox
primarily but i do feel like if we're
going more close more towards a free to
uh uh you know a cross-play cross
progression model where everything is
cross-play cross progress yeah like we
do need discord to be active on all the
platforms like playstation needs to do
it nintendo needs to do it that way when
we play stuff like fall guys
playstation doesn't have to join an xbox
live party they could join a there's
like there's like a middle ground
everyone could just join the discord
call and then we'll be fine we don't
have to like they don't have to mingle
with each other's wires if that makes
sense right
no i love it man um you know what this
actually
has affected me before actually recently
uh last weekend or two weeks ago my boy
sean 786 you know but
he was live streaming fall guys and and
halo infinite
and um
by me playing on my console i had to be
on discord on my phone and it was like
dirt you sound like crap
i'm on my phone man i don't know what to
tell you
you know so
yeah so now that it's going to be
integrated until
into the console i think that's a that's
huge man that's huge and you made a
perfect example of cross cross play
games and even people there's some
people that this
is really comfortable using discord
all right there are some people that
love to use discord over xbox live
parties and you can get how many people
discord is there a limit um like what's
the limit you can get people in discord
i think it just depends on what the
discord server says okay okay i got you
okay do you think there is a limit like
i don't think you can have like 700 and
one disclosure right yeah no i think the
max i've seen is like like 20 something
maybe okay close to 30 but that depends
also if the server is boosted
regrettably i think that'll okay
but it is more than 16 the standard xbox
live 16 though right yeah i mean but
that's a lot of people in one party but
yeah i think it's good man any any new
perk or any new uh thing that that i'm
going to use or even if i don't use just
a bonus to gamers in general whether
it's xbox or playstation or even
nintendo i love it man i love it even if
like i said like even if it's something
i'm not going to use
there's somebody else that will use it
so yeah i love it man um kudos to xbox
who are actually getting this done
i i think it's uh good you know we do
need that middle ground
i feel like when you play fortnite there
are games believe it or not that don't
have voice chat i i don't know why you
would it's crazy
games without voice i don't think
battlefield had voice chat when it first
came out it didn't that's true it didn't
yeah that's a triple a product they
don't have the best voice chat like i
forgot about that minecraft doesn't
either to my knowledge because i
remember trying to
play
voice with someone on playstation
and it wouldn't let me
like you can't hear them we had to join
a discord call
and that's why i feel like this is a
huge win for everyone now
obviously you know we're going to talk a
little bit more in depth on the the
discord thing but let's let's bring
playstation into the picture uh you know
uh big cloud do you
well first off big cloud get your
opinions on the discord thing in general
then we'll move to the playstation thing
well first of all nobody
hardly uses the in-game voice chat as it
is on these consoles so the fact that we
got this as a better alternative is dope
i'm surprised sony doesn't have this
that's what i thought they were gonna
have when they said they were doing that
whole um
kind of like merger thing when you can
like uh see your who's playing what
on discord uh if they're if you link it
with your psn or something like that i
thought they were gonna do something
like that where you can just naturally
do that but no they they didn't do that
you just see who's what they're playing
that's about it it doesn't tell you
anything else about that uh account
so that's cool though it's dope you can
actually do this and also it's more
convenient for a lot of us because a lot
of us really do hang out more mostly in
our custom servers so absolutely if you
want to get away from like a certain
crowd on your place or your xbox in this
case like you don't want to be bothered
or not like that you don't have to worry
about that you'd be legit in your own
server and have that dirt and also like
a direct link to your friends you really
really think about it you invite only
people you close to to that particular
server and then bam you're done so that
right there is
again it's a quick way of getting to you
like your top let's say 10 50 friends or
just people you rock with in general and
that's that's actually pretty cool yeah
hopefully sony was to do something
i don't know
one thing i will say that i respect
microsoft for
is their ability to put their ego aside
uh you know the skype clearly is what
they run the xbox servers on when it
comes to uh the voice chat
um
i'm pretty sure it's still skype so it's
just i mean they might have switched to
the teams i don't know but right now i'm
thinking that skype you know they could
easily just keep going on that and have
that mentality where it's like look
if you want
to
listen and talk with our xbox community
you got to use the skype servers by
joining the xbox
parties but microsoft's like
we'll go where they are are our
customers want to be
integrated into the discord
so we're gonna do that and what what i
like is how in-depth the integration is
like when you join a discord party
it looks like an xbox live party but it
has the discord emblem instead yeah
and i i really appreciate that man and
you know we'll go ahead like i said
we'll bring the playstation perspective
into it like what do you guys think how
if time frame
if you think they will will adopt the
same thing into the playstation uh uh
system
what kind of time frame and if you don't
they clearly just say no uh dirt what
you thinking
i think it depends on how successful it
is on xbox um
i think you know i think sony pays
attention obviously they pay attention
to everything that's going on
and if it kind of takes off on xbox i'm
sure sony would do i mean it's probably
in the plans now you know i'm saying
maybe they didn't do it for whatever
reason as far as the voice chat part of
it um the full integration but yeah
absolutely man
if it goes over well on the xbox side i
guarantee playstation will do it also as
far as time frame
who knows
maybe a year two years maybe it's taking
them like eight years to get gifting
going so oh [ __ ] oh god i don't think
you ever can get gift again
it's kind of i know unless the pc that's
the pc thing have the over the day and
date thing happens immediately then
that's why i think the gifting will be
officially
incorporated but right now the fact you
have a wish list
for the sake of having a wish list is
kind of pointless to me so
what
what are your perspective and your
opinions on if if sony gonna jump on
this eventually and if they're not do
you think that they're going to
i mean again uh dirk said it perfectly
um if it depends on the popularity if
it's really really like a success and
everybody's like like talking about it
and there's a lot of like discussion
whether it be on twitter or in forums um
then yeah i i could see sony jumping on
board maybe take one to two years to
respond uh to get started two years
maybe the degeneration gonna be almost
over by the time they respond
hey you know how so the thing about sony
sony
you think sony's gonna react the way you
would expect right but then they they
move on their time look at nintendo
nintendo is the only one out of this
group
that will never have discord on their
system absolutely
you said i'm saying and they didn't even
care about it exactly and people are
still gonna buy
that console because it's a handheld and
they're gonna make excuses they're gonna
say well it's a handheld i do blah blah
blah i don't need voice chat but it's
like if you had it you'd be praising it
yeah
you're right yeah are you absolutely
right bro that was so they said they you
know listen man they um they pay
attention and they move see even if you
go back to the ps3 generation
like we all know they didn't release
with trophies but they saw the gamer
score was oh okay
so let's implement our own little
version of it
so
they pay attention excuse me
they pay attention to everything
and if it takes off
they're going to add it guarantee
for some reason
i feel like the playstation
wasn't built for something like this
like the like the the back in the
software in uh obviously sony could
probably restructure a lot of it to
incorporate this into it but i do feel
like microsoft
most
some most time have edges when it comes
to incorporating stuff onto their stores
it feels like xbox
the xbox one throughout that whole
generation they redesigned it to be more
adaptable you know what i'm saying where
if they needed to redirect something or
make something look different it was a
lot easier it looks like because
microsoft does it so often but when it
comes to playstation
yeah when it comes to playstation we
still don't have gifting uh you know
there's a lot of features that people
want that's on xbox that's not on
playstation and the fact that gifting is
such an easy concept but they haven't
done yet makes me feel maybe they didn't
design the
psn to be adaptable like that maybe you
have to go in and it takes a lot more
work than something like microsoft doing
it to xbox so that's why they don't do
it
because if you look at it from like
when you see the updates on playstation
they might add something to it or tweak
something but it's never drastic you
know what i'm saying like they never
drastically change anything on that
dashboard they just will you know move
something somewhere or update something
but you never see anything
huge being changed on that so that's
what makes me feel like you know unless
it's huge priority
i don't think that you know they're
willing to put the resources and time
into something like that but discord is
a huge thing
and if people start talking about xbox a
lot because they feel like they have
more access to their friends they have
more access to playing games with people
because
you have access to
discord
then that might be something that makes
it a priority where they're willing to
do something with
discord yeah we know you're not going to
be in uh in discord addiction we're even
going to put you in all right see now
because xbox big cloud has gave me the
opportunity to go says this but watch
addicts world on ilp be empty every
single day it is empty every single day
it's dryer oh it's going down
it's going to be drier than a desert in
there
that's one of the reasons because like
all my friends are on xbox and you know
i might jump in discord every now and
then when i'm bored bored i got to be
bored bored before i jump in discord
like i got to be bored bored like damn
near nothing else to do before i jump in
discord uh but you know
about five o'clock when you decide to
jump in or four you just like you'd be
dead on the mic jumping in the districts
i hope playstation does adapt this and i
hope nintendo does eventually because i
do feel like if all the the major
platforms has discord where everyone can
integrate with them you'll see more
cross play more cross progression i
don't think crossplay and cross
progression are going to go down i think
the longer time goes the more companies
are going to start to do it uh do you
think they're having trouble with
licensing that's why gifting is not a
thing maybe
like if they were to do this because you
know again you're you're transferring a
license to another player maybe they
don't have this and then once again what
maybe they're having trouble with
licensing because playstation wasn't
initially designed to gift games like
that
so they have to restructure something
drastically because if you remember
the cart's been there for a while hasn't
it
yeah yeah yeah so you know they found
that as a priority and one would think
that
you would try to make sure gifting is
implemented into your system because it
encourages more people to spend their
money to get more money
you know
you know how easy it is when we let me
tell you guys something when we give
away games on iop it is so much easier
on xbox because we just hadn't need
their email address and we gift it to
them directly from the store when we do
playstation it's a bunch of hoops man we
got to do front loops front hoops back
hoops side hoops it's crazy it looks
like i'm playing fall guys the way i
have to be gifting on playstation uh but
you you know they need to fix that they
need better
uh you know implements and features uh
you know and people need to hold them to
the fire you know dirt
dirt they got got to hold them to the
fire man we need we need more features
over there and gifting it's like i said
the gifting doesn't seem like a negative
thing at all for them to do uh you know
besides the initial investment it takes
to
get it into the sit to the store and
implement it
all that's going to do is encourage
people to play more games and buy more
games and buy more dlc so i don't
understand why that still is a thing
that they still haven't done
to me
at that point
it has to be
the amount of time it takes they don't
see
as being worth
doing that effort
yeah
i mean
maybe it's just not that important to
him right now
that's all i can say man maybe it's just
not that important to him right now
they're trying to make sure god of war
don't get delayed in 2023
it's so hard to be messy y'all in the
chat i'm playing around yeah yeah yeah
i'm talking to this one pony uh
you know i told him this just love 2022.
enjoy
enjoy 2022 because yes xbox doesn't have
any triple a games just enjoy it keep on
cherishing xbox has no games love it for
the rest of the year go ahead we could
talk about that real quick because i do
want to bring up
the netflix thing briefly um
look xbox is in terms of first party you
know it is pretty dry and uh
2022 is an l for xbox in terms of their
first party but here's the thing like
regardless how we feel about it
what what is a year
to a to a to a company that makes
platforms and develop games
it sucks for as a consumer
but if the games start rolling out and
they're good
nobody's gonna talk about the year that
xbox had like two games the entire year
but yeah they're going to talk about the
year where they're thriving for sure
yeah and that's what i'm saying like
look like
you know
that's why i got a playstation and a
switch because you know i'm always going
to have something to play play you know
always that always mad at gaming that
your name says it all man
you always mad at gaming because clearly
you you don't how do you play games and
always be mad at gaming
like clearly that that that's a troll
account
it is what it is they say it's chris
hart they said it's chris hart it's
chris he asked him
it's just like look like
i play everything you know that's why
i'm
so adamant about god of war coming out
there's because this is
it's rough in these streets right now
man you know that's good there's decent
there's decent games coming out but
there's nothing that's like
chef's kiss
like yeah
well no with kalisto protocol but that's
that's that's next year no it's this
year no that's december oh that's
getting pushed in
january you think so
yeah well well like the dead space
remake is in january yeah i'm saying
yeah nah what do you think's going to do
better dead space or kalisto protocol
kalisto i think you know i'm actually
working i'm working on getting a
developer on here uh from callisto
protocol one of the uh lead developers
nice uh so you know we'll we'll crack it
up with him talking hopefully if that
goes through yeah but you know
let's move on to this netflix thing
netflix
and xbox have partnered up for their
ad-free subscription model on netflix
um we all know what happened man
microsoft makes any type of
partnership that's on a huge scale
people automatically start
like reaching man like mr fantastic
reaching
so what i want to ask you guys is you
know what is your initial
thoughts when you saw this and then now
that things have calmed down a little
bit what's your thoughts on it now we'll
start with with uh dirt
microsoft buying netflix what's going on
man
okay let me tell you this i i just don't
know no i got to be honest some of my
xbox brothers and sisters they do jump
out there they want you know see they
know microsoft is one of the richest
companies in the world and clearly
microsoft is spending money right now
and uh so sometimes we get decided by
netflix buy capcom come on man let's
just calm down
let's look at it
as it is it's a business partnership
with microsoft and netflix now can this
possibly lead to other things down the
line absolutely i mentioned the other
day
um that
possibly
xcloud could go to netflix
you know
i think that can be huge
just imagine
every netflix account or you know like
whatever tier they decide to
put game pass on
that can be huge i mean like this
imagine you you you know like you watch
a movie like you know uh like you watch
the witcher you watch something else you
go play the witcher game or you know
things like that so that's definitely a
possibility in the future and if that
happened don't be surprised that xbox
will say hey yo
xbox game pass subs is that 220 million
now you know they just kind of combine
netflix with uh xbox games but
yeah so uh you know
i think it's cool but as of right now
i'm just going to look at it as what it
is it's a partnership i'm not going to
speculate i mean it's cool to talk about
that kind of stuff to be honest with you
especially in dry times like right now
but not a lot of gaming news we have to
kind of you know
kind of run with things yeah we got to
wing it so it is fun to talk about
saying what will microsoft buy netflix
and things like that but i'm not going
to go that far
yet but i think you know it's a cool
partnership or whatever their their
their ad tier or whatever like netflix
is trying to
get in the gaming they're trying to get
again yeah they are cuz they have like
some mobile games
now and you know i think like i think
netflix might be plateauing
to where they're not really gaining
they're losing some
and they're trying to you know like you
said
get something else to
like you know
yeah they want to keep people subscribed
and a lot of people the thing is a lot
of people unsubscribe like me i
unsubscribe when a certain show season
is not there like i'm waiting to
september god we're so close but
september i'm i'll be back on that cause
cobra guy season five right yeah i'm
looking forward to that one too yeah so
you know that's where i'll be back on
but
yeah netflix just
aside from a few shows that's about it
most of the movies on here you think
about it they don't have i don't know if
y'all caught on to this but it doesn't
look like it's not like they had
everything that day you know i mean like
they had all the higher end movies you
know i mean no those licenses got a
little too expensive so now you have a
few
in the barrel right and use competition
out there now too bro yes a lot too
yeah you know
that's what i wanted to say like you
know i saw people like a shout out to
paris literally saying that you know
netflix needs to incorporate more
you know weekly week yeah i think that's
completely
no one is not no one's leaving netflix
because they can't watch all their stuff
because they they watch all their stuff
in a couple months like i get it the
concept to that is people are go uh
people are watching all they're bench
watching it a couple days and then they
have nothing to watch the rest of the
month but it's just like look like
amazon
all they got is the boys like yes yeah
it's okay to have it it's okay to have
like a mindset
that as a content creator
you want them to be released weekly so
you can make content weekly
but as a consumer
what does that really benefit you
like nothing right
like you have to wait a week to watch
something like and then that that's
not that's mentioning that the people
bench watching or watching it in a day
or two
i know people that's still watching
stranger things three or four weeks
later yeah like the reason people are
leaving netflix is because hey they keep
raising their prices more than the rest
of the the the industry b they keep
canceling shows that people actually
like and see
like dirk grigga he said
back then they could do all this and
they would still grow because there was
no competition
for the most part people had like that
one little show
wasn't really that big of a show but it
was like a show
yeah they were like back then they had
um remember correctly back then they had
buffy the vampires they had angel they
had all the classic they had a bunch of
that stuff yeah yeah i was like damn
nostalgia overall let me watch you know
i'm gonna subscribe now they're gone it
looks well i'm scared like
netflix i still consider is the king of
the crop when it comes to streaming
because they still have the most
shows that that that helps
yeah i agree but the problem is is five
ten years ago probably more like five
when you looked at these other streaming
services there wasn't a level uh the hbo
max that was him getting out hits there
wasn't amazon that's throwing out the
boys there wasn't exactly plus
dude actually probably one of the better
of them all and then there wasn't stuff
like peacock having their own exclusive
video uh movie shows
yeah it was netflix and that's all
like if you wanted the the exclusive
shows and the the tv shows that you
enjoyed you had to go to netflix there
was no other choice
but now there's competition there's
people bidding for this stuff there's
people who go there's people that say
okay
we will pay you
to let just at least put your stuff on
us you can be for the streets we just
want to be part of the streets like
right
and now it's it's it's not necessarily
about fighting for exclusivity it's
about just staying relevant and making
sure the actual content is on your
system on the narrative and that's why
that's why i'm so adamant about the the
jrpgs and stuff like it's the same
concept like it has to be on the system
it doesn't matter if it's not an
exclusive at that point it's gotta for
the bare minimum be on the system
yep
i agree
with you
and that's why i feel like you know
we do got to do better as a community as
content creators and influencers and
media
stop hyping up everything into
everything that it's not you know
if you start seeing more because then
what we do
we influence 230 people into thinking
netflix is by being bought by microsoft
225 people go on twitter and say
addictive dirt and b big cloud told me
that microsoft's buying netflix and then
before you know what those 225 people
they might fall they might between them
all follow
have like maybe 10 000 followers and
then before you know them 10 000
followers of people saying i saw
somewhere on the internet that
microsoft's buying netflix before you
know it netflix
next to philips is trending on on
twitter like that's how this stuff works
that's uh that's how it would be you
know i don't understand it they don't
understand
unrealistic expectations
you know
we have a yearly e3 what's that e3 thing
and you know
i kind of overlooked that you could go a
little bit at balls to the wall with
that particular event because that's
what we're there we're there to to hype
people up we're there to like you know
speculate uh but you know some people
like kid smooth and boom
they go away balls to the wall when it
comes to those events they you know
smooth was saying release dates
okay release date
so
it is just like to a point
when the hype is killing a game
at that point who's to blame is it the
influencers and the content creators
that's influencing this massive amounts
of people
into having this unrealistic expectation
or is it the developers that don't meet
that unrealistic expectation
what did i say about cyberpunk addicts
that's a good example right there yeah
but i do feel like cyberpunk was a
different beast
if cyberpunk would have came out and
worked i think it would have met
expectations no no but the thing was
this though remember it was their first
new ip and everybody was putting these
unrealistic expectations of what it was
gonna do and we didn't see anything then
we were getting confirmation of stuff
being cut
from the game
for example third person remember that
that was the big thing in customization
that was cut and people like oh there's
nothing to worry about first person is
bad third i'm like
okay
even though we're talking about
customization there you know and then
the game drops it's
not it's not even a fraction of what
they were talking about so
i don't know man it takes
this community it's a give and take
when it comes to over hype and stuff
like you know sometimes a little hype is
good and then there's others who just
over hype everything for the sake of
that oneness and
that's why it never ends well yeah
that's why there are scenarios where
it does need to be
met
you know cyberpunk if you know people
are hyping the hell out of your game
delay that sucker and get it at least
working like what why are you wanting to
fight up a hill like there's people up
the hill with spears and pikes you're
gonna lose
like like i don't understand why
developers and publishers feel like they
can win against the internet you can't
it don't matter how much money you have
you could be a trillionaire you're never
going to win the internet the internet
is going to beat you up drag you home
show your face to your to to that like
little what's the little uh right no
scanner they're gonna open the door and
they're gonna beat your whole family up
that's the internet like they don't care
that's why like i don't understand why
people are okay with putting out broken
games you're going to get roasted you've
literally killed your game before it
even comes out five dollars super chat
from yo baby farva
i i hope i i didn't butcher that but
we're gonna keep going on what's up
fellas great chat addicts showing
dedication streaming for beach for us my
guy dirt always on point hey man look at
that what's funny is uh
what's up with your baby farmer yeah i
appreciate the support man i use this uh
on iop and people
lost
they mined
like it and i i didn't look i'mma be
real with you i didn't expect
people to go this crazy over this but i
i use this
you could use two like if you go if you
go to if you go to video and you click
the little arrow thing
uh and then you go to um
the
the video settings
and then what you do is you go to
background and effects you go to avatar
beta
you can turn yourself into an animal too
we can all be animals
i love it i'm going to talk like this
yeah that's fire oh yeah please please
find a horse that would be so epic i
don't know why like i'm not normally
part of the uh the console or stuff but
you could turn yourself into a pony
that's funny bro
we the animal podcast today man there
you go
you say go where how you saying the
background filters you go to the video
video settings you go to background
filters and avatar beta yes sir
so hey guys welcome to the attic show
where your dreams
it just says virtual backgrounds and
video filters and that's all yeah yep
you might have to update your uh zoom
oh okay but yeah
yeah that's funny
let me turn it off before uh we get
sidetracked because i keep i keep
looking at myself man but uh
[Laughter]
oh my god that's stupid
oh look at the end of the day it's like
i said the the biggest thing i just want
well when it comes to the netflix thing
it's just
oh man
the animal thing threw me out completely
out of it
yeah animal crossing look all i want is
games to come out and not be broken
there we go
let's move on to to the meat and
potatoes man
uh there's a lot of speculation going on
that the xbox and activision deal is
closing down
it's about to end yeah so i'm kind of
curious what you guys opinion on this
now i've talked to dirt a few times
about i haven't had bitclad on in a
while
you know
obviously this activision thing is it
was rumored months ago to be finishing
out of the beginning of next year
but if it does finish a little early do
you think that might change options for
microsoft this holiday or do you think
you know what they had planned is going
to be what goes down
start with big cloud
uh
you know uh
in terms of change
hmm
i don't know about i don't know it
depends honestly and how quick they can
uh get everything going like for example
the biggest quick change i could see
happening if it was the deal was to
finish quickly um would be call of duty
obviously in game best like the ogs and
game pass as far as like the newer ones
i could definitely see it if they wanted
to do something like that and partner
with it but if anything
before we start getting into that
they'll probably start doing custom
consoles along with that as well and get
into heavy marketing with that being the
poster boy or one of their poster boys
for
the console in game fest because
right now haloing it you know i'm saying
you need something massive to uh get
behind so i think that would be it
uh their strategic way of going about it
would you feel dirt you feel like
something's gonna change you know i
agree with what bray claus said if the
deal
is finalized say within let me say
september just for an example september
i do believe what he just said i think
they're going to throw all the
activision blizzard games and game pass
now with the exception
of the the brand new call of duty now
now the reason i say the exception
because
we don't know what type of deal sony has
because they still have the marketing
rights for call of duty this year
do they have no game pass deal i don't
know but yeah i totally
huh
yeah yeah i think i do remember
something like that
there was a deal with that i went there
yeah i remember
after
a couple of the games i remember
sony started implementing
those type of of cl clauses
yeah yeah but
this call of duty deal was probably made
in like 2013-14
like yeah but you got to keep in mind
you got to keep in mind though how many
games were on that contract as well you
know i mean you got this one you
probably got the next one and the one
after that so yeah probably got like
three
maybe four in total and then once that
is up then obviously microsoft is free
to do whatever hell they want and yeah
marketing uh with it so
what i just see is more so mostly the
legacy titles
in his way to the service just to add a
little bit more like going yeah guys you
guys want to play the ogs you know the
servers and everything they're up
they're on you know again
go check those out and that would be
their way of um getting you into the
service even more and
what sony does later on and again
because sony knows this they don't they
can't rely on call of duty as a crutch
anymore that's why they're making
service games
and they got bungie
now helping them with this bungie is
like their big saving grace when it
comes to multiplayer games because
they're not good and they're not really
their greatest when it comes to
multiplayer games so bundy's gonna lend
their expertise and and fix that you
know what happens if they buy you clown
huh i'm gonna say what happens if they
buy bungee and all these service case
flops
they're doing 10 but i think one more
unlikely is guaranteed to hit and that's
factions depending on how well that is
done factors could be their
gears of war if done right their gear is
online if properly done it can be like
that one um another one that could
happen i mean again we're not you you
forgot about legacy towers that could
potentially come back with uh with socom
and resistance i see those coming back
with insomniac overseeing
resistance so there's a lot of stuff
they can go back and grab and go listen
bungie
we need that multiplayer to be yeah we
need to be fired you know what i mean
i want to give you problems
real quick let me address something
people in the chat are coming at me
because i said that
what i i didn't say most likely a lot of
these was gonna hit i would just say it
would be crazy if they spent that kind
of money on bungie and it didn't help
them with their games that's all i'm
saying yeah don't worry don't worry
don't don't mind at it y'all his beard's
too heavy that's all
now let me say
no i want to give you props because i
wholeheartedly agree with what you said
they can't rely on pod anymore like they
used to because it was obviously xbox is
going to own them so that's why i always
said them buying bungee was a good move
because it's not about destiny it's
definitely not about destiny 2.
it's about bungie's expertise yeah
absolutely it's about their expertise
with live service games and multiplayer
this is on the gamepl and i thought
it wouldn't be the smartest purchase but
then when i looked at it from a
strategic point of view like you know
like ubisoft now there was reports that
sony was looking to buy ubisoft it was
like a big thing going around for that
if sony acquired ubisoft they would have
all the legroom and not to mention the
workforce
to push more games out here than what we
personally seen and that's a lot more
hands-on on projects i'm saying
that could have definitely benefited
these
service place games to begin with and on
top of that
expertise being pushed to other stuff
such as
legacy back and pad types we've been
talking about that for a long time
they're looking for solutions now
they're talking about multi-layered gpus
to fix their cloud solution
it's like
they know
they have some holes in their game that
they have to iron out there's a lot of
stuff because streaming games sounds
cool on paper
but it's not the it's not the proper fix
it doesn't be native support you know
you just plug it in a disc and hey look
the game's up hey look trophies are
popping as opposed to me you know
hitting stream and hit with lag and all
this no no it doesn't it doesn't work
like that it just it just it won't work
like that yeah
i agree with you man i'm hungry and my
boy other zinc in the chat man but
others they be talking that trash hey
what's up dog
i guess when it comes to me i i just
want to see more consistency with all
that um i do want to see
them have that the biggest thing i want
that i'm curious on is that bethesda
round table conference
show they had like right i want to see
if they have something similar of
activision where they sit around
with uh hopefully barbie won't be there
but you know you know bobby be
like i'll be in the restroom stay in
there buddy
bobby ain't gonna be in the restroom
probably gonna be eating five-star hotel
room oh yeah that's why you can get all
the money right they gonna buy them out
you ride them
they're gonna break them off they're
gonna buy them out like yo man they're
gonna be like he he walks up and uh the
moment they like sign the deal and
they're in that room
they look above like all right you gotta
leave the building now
security get this guy there
hey but hey i think they will have that
right that same type of round table
with you know like they have with any
max once the deal is finalized like i
really do believe that and i believe
they're going to break down what it you
know i'm the type of guy i do believe
that you know kai will remain
multi-player obviously
overwatch 2
uh will remain multiplied and diablo 4.
more likely to get some perks some crazy
person after everything
why not do that though you you guys
remember the multiplayer not the most
like the um the maps from the
multiplayer yeah back then how like
microsoft or sony would get them early
well here's the thing they can do
something completely different with game
pass incorporated they can get it for
free for game passes yeah
or in early you said i'm saying there's
a lot of perks they can throw into this
with the impasse so absolutely man plus
plus i do believe that future
games new ips will be exclusive to the
platform like the platform because i
already said activision blizzard is
making some do i plea
some new ip on the blizzard side that's
going to be uh
exclusive to xbox yeah dude
yeah
i do think because
of warzone
there's a good chance that call of duty
from now on is a year is a bi-year game
like yeah yeah i agree with you i don't
think they
you know their their mindsets like look
like we might lose some money on the
back end a little bit because call of
duty's not coming out yearly but then
we'll take some of those resources that
was going into making call of duty every
year and we'll amp up warzone to make
that even more successful um i think
they they'll snatch some of the devs i
do think that you're probably gonna
start like two to three developers maybe
working on call of duty but i like six
uh right some of those developers this
year everybody's working on it like all
of their studios that i've thought that
i read is
working on the game this year all of
them
raven treyarch
it's like all of them doing something
great thing is sony even got um former
cod devs on the government of fire
sprite fire it's the former cod
developers too so it's
it's going again it's going to be
interesting generation it really is and
how everybody plays ball and how the
pieces fall online uh how things go
you know sony already got one massive
seller
guaranteed to push them really far in
2023 and that spider-man
would not even count on wolverine which
is probably going to be 2024
maybe at dallas 2023 i think that's
winning 24.
it's gonna be interesting i'm actually
uh looking forward to that imagine that
day i wake up in the morning to cod
all card games have reached game pass
that's gonna be good you ain't gonna
play neither because you suck
yeah i i i'm definitely not playing no
call of duty
i ain't capping on that man called games
don't get along but
i've actually
you know
there's just a lot of aspects to this
call of duty deal uh to this activision
deal in general like i said even if they
go about making
call of duty a
year by year game where it's not year by
year it's by yearly
just the games that they free up and the
opportunities that they give people i
feel is going to be
huge for them because there are a lot of
like little things that microsoft needs
that i do feel like those studios can
handle
you know um what there's like a
um
what let me look up the activision
studios again i can't remember all right
you know what it is
um yeah guitar has one um
please well please don't let that come
out
crash bandicoot is another spyro pitfall
you go back to pitfall
please though
oh man
what's about to say um so you're pretty
much waiting for the obviously when doom
hits the store
as well as elder scrolls again they have
a lot of leverage why it's like it's
just the waiting
which i understand it it's weird you
know i mean we were talking about this
bear just nothing to really show but
you know once that stuff is shown
then you know you'll be you'll be fine
tony hall yeah i forgot about tony hawk
tony hall all right so i'm looking at uh
the studios now uh so you know they own
quite a bit i don't think people really
realize how like many studios that they
actually own
uh
prototype
so they they own you know in
studios within their studios
like raven studios infinity war high
moon studios and other people that
helped with destiny
i remember high moon yeah yeah and
i i don't know activision shanghai i
think that's what it's called uh
okay so let me
um infinity war red moon uh that's just
you know pretty much sledgehammer games
clearly i actually got a cousin that
works at sledgehammer
toys for bob that's what i was thinking
about toys for crash four was amazing by
the way that game was under overlooked
and underrated didn't that come on game
pass or like
or something just released on plus yeah
yeah that was a great name over there it
looked good i loved uh the insane
trilogy i just been one the one to play
no one so nothing else so i mean look
you look at treyarch you know you look
at all these studios now i do think
treyarch infinity war
they're still going to work on call of
duty they're going to be oh absolutely
absolutely uh i do think sledgehammer
might be turned into a support studio
uh you know they might
have a good more amount of their people
help you i think they'll work on smaller
games like double a games but i don't
think they're going to work on any more
aaa products for a while
um but you know and then you look at
companies like raven studio uh their
studio that could easily make something
uh studio they they can easily make
something like you know you give a lot
of these studios a little bit of a
budget to show you what they can do and
you'll be surprised what they do
that's why i'm excited for uh jade
raymond and uh
yeah haven't studios i'm excited for
what they're working on yeah
yeah he's got you know
there's toys for
toys for bob that's who i want to make
like a banjo or conquer uh i think
they'll be perfect uh i also is they're
the people that make the crash bandicoot
games
yeah
they may crash for them tell you oh they
may crash for um you know what they
should think about terminal i'm thinking
about terminal reality i think that's
what made the insane geology yeah they
should make i always thought they would
be cool as like a a crash bandicoot and
spiral game like combined
yeah like a collab game belongs that
they did a crash bandicoot and a
banjo-kazooie combined game like
laura like uh you only remember that
game crash bash
i don't remember that one yummer crash
bash where there's like a bunch of party
games you can like um oh the party i i
do it remember
it was like it was like like a thing
where you had to eliminate everybody
kill each other like that is the last
one i actually and have bosses i know
this would never happen but you know how
cool it would be
since we have like this cross playing
cross progression so accepted
that
nintendo
contra that microsoft
sony and nintendo the people who make
super smash brothers they make three
versions of that one for every platform
with all their ip characters and then
cross play where if you play with the
other people
you play their other they're like
exclusive games
so like if if you're playing like um
kind of like remember what they did with
the soul calibur like there was a link
on one yeah
and so i remember that do that but on a
bigger scale to where like if if i'm
playing someone on playstation it's
nintendo players versus playstation
players
like cradles like i think that would
work so well imagine how much money that
game would make
yeah i mean sony you can tell if sony
wants to do another playstation
all-stars but uh
probably nobody wants
the first one a lot of people want it
but the problem with the first one was
they didn't have the roster they took a
lot of uh
they couldn't even get crashed in the
game they had to kill yeah hey microsoft
has a raw suit yes
so
i i definitely think um playstation can
make one of those but microsoft got some
crazy ideas now oh absolutely absolutely
yeah
doom guy yes
that's why my dream for microsoft is is
a lot of collab
studio effort i'd like for studios to
work together to make games like i
mentioned i like um you know to see
obsidian and bethesda's software studios
collab to make fallout 5.
another one that i think would be really
cool is uh take um
um what's that studio called um the one
that made psychonauts
double fine double fine collabing with
rare to make a banjo yeah uh you know i
and people like obviously
double fine said they don't want to make
a banjo but that's just the higher the
higher ups you know they want to do what
they want to but there's plenty of
people in these studios that have
ambition and they've proven themselves
and if you gave them a student like a
team to work on a game
they would they would hit it out of the
park
and that that's why i feel like instead
of waiting eight years for a fallout
let obsidian
and bethesda work on it together with
maybe 20 30 people from bethesda 20 30
people from
from uh fall uh from
uh from uh obsidian
then upscale it when it gets to mass
production and then you would have a
game because my thing is i don't want to
wait
i feel like waiting five years to start
working on fallout 5 is a mistake
because that is such a big rpg moment i
get it we gotten to the point where
microsoft has so many rpgs
it doesn't really make sense to just
start another developing on another one
but to me
once these once these these studios
start getting their games out it would
be nice to just knock on a door and be
like fallout 5 drop in a year after
elder scrolls 6. you know what i'm
saying like
that that's just my opinion it's just
like look man we
we need
more games not less and i feel like you
know microsoft is in a particular
opportunity where they can do stuff like
that where you can see a spiral with a
crash bandicoot game or a you know
spiral pro crash bandicoot i think
because he's such a
uh a unique personality character would
probably work better with like a
conqueror
or
actually that would be crazy conquer and
spy and crash bandicoot yeah you have
conquer like just on the screen and all
of a sudden you hear you hear no no it's
lightning and he starts shooting down
imagine what's that what's that mass
that follows crash around oh uh
the the evil the evil one
imagine a like a banjo-kazooie type of
game
but instead of kazooie it's crash
bandicoot and conquer
yeah and imagine like conquer and crash
and that that mass fighting all the time
you know what i'm saying yeah like the
evil like the evil one probably corrupts
conqueror or something and crash gotta
save him or something i don't know i
think it would be cool dude i think like
situations like that
but like i could just see conker making
fun of him saying that
it just i i think there's a lot of
opportunities that microsoft has you
know
sony got a little bit of them but you
know i do feel like microsoft
has just the raw power to make some of
these games that necessarily some people
don't
yeah yeah so you know
yeah
like you know ending the show with this
whole activision thing what what is your
expectations with that what
as i say we're in the show we gotta end
the show with the animal but
oh well i'm mad i can't do it i gotta
update it yeah yeah okay we got it you
know what you gotta do it next week
we'll have the whole show for a couple
minutes is
so what is your expectations with the
zak division deal like in the long run
uh we'll go short run and long run start
with uh uh big cloud what's your
expectations when it comes to
the near short future maybe six months
to a year and a half and then maybe
three years on
okay um so if the deal is finished again
just going off of what we said earlier a
short
end of the whole thing um i can see them
quickly acting and going hey guys um the
og classics all you know call of duty's
are in here so if you guys want to play
those legacy uh games during here
servers
are up that'd be pretty badass you can
go play those and experience those on
pcn console so you can get on that and
have fun with those
um that'd be cool
and
the long-term haul
i mean there's so much you can take from
it especially after the contracts are
done with microsoft in the uh the deal
like we said earlier sony can't rely on
call of duty no more as a crutch for a
multiplayer solution so
this would be microsoft's ace player
in terms of selling their ecosystem um
you will have ghosts more likely on the
cover or one of the poster boys for game
best you would probably see custom laser
edge consoles uh to
go with this and i can actually see them
doing something with gamestop where you
buy the console you get this game pass
get all that stuff and that will be the
theme going for that you can also see um
really
the other thing i can see for this too
is dlc
and um how they handle
um micro transactions and whatnot with
the console so microsoft will more
likely get the dlc rights again
ironically they're the ones who started
that trend so it'd be crazy if they just
did it all over again but this time they
do it in a crazier way where you get
everything
not only earlier but
imagine you guys get it you get all this
stuff with call of duty at no additional
cost it's exclusive to game pass members
like that's an exclusive for game pass
members so you don't have to pay an
additional cost for being a game pass
remember and you get all the dlc and
whatnot for it that'd be pretty badass
as well but the first thing i do expect
to see though obviously is the legacy
games on there and it'll be cool if they
also um boosted those games
that would be awesome um pretty cool too
so that's what i would say
my screen first there you go yeah what
about you dirt what what what what a
short term expectations for short and
long term with this deal i agree with uh
big cloud um
a short term just like with any max if
you guys remember excuse me after the
deal was finalized
it seems like within a few days they
threw
that zeni max back catalogic games into
game pass to see him i just threw them
all in there excuse me so
i totally expect that
from all activision blizzard and also
with the short term i i fully expect
after the contract is finalized uh
you know some maybe diablo 4 will go
into game pass pc and console
i think overwatch tools are free to play
anyway all right
overwatch
yeah but what's funny is they have like
a uh a paid version of it it's like 40
bucks you can actually have access to
the game right now
oh okay
it's like the beta of it or something
like that i don't know if it's still
available but i saw people playing it
and they said they got it for that
particular bundle so i'm curious if
that's like
the beta was that weak and now you just
pay 40 dollars for nothing
or if
you have access to a beta until the
actual game comes out
yeah so um so yeah i agree with
everything you said i do believe
um also well that's more long term so
i'll say it when we go a long time
but yeah i agree with what big offset so
what what what's your long-term goals
man what you expect well now i'm a long
time turn goal he he kind of glit up a
little bit there he's like oh you know
how it is with xbox man we know we got
to look at the future man you know now
but long term i uh
do believe
um
when when the contract with playstation
is over where i do believe you will
see those games in game pass day one the
brand new ones even you know what i'm
still not sure if if there's some type
of language in those contracts saying
those games cannot go into game pass
from playstation side because like you
said mitch i mean like you guys
mentioned earlier there was definitely
some type of language in their marketing
deals that said these games cannot go
into
game pass for a set amount of time so i
do um i definitely see
um
special themed consoles in the future
exclusive titles in the future maybe
they do like another crash in the future
or whatever these teams are going to
make
with xbox they're going to be exclusive
titles from activision blizzard
division yeah actually absolutely
because call of duty is still a huge
game a huge franchise
and um that being under xbox um umbrella
means a lot the marketing itself is
worth more than the deal absolutely man
absolutely
if you think about the 360 generation
the entire generation
actually
we saw call of duty kind of become this
juggernaut during the xbox 360 ps3
generation the entire generation excuse
me it seemed like xbox had the marketing
deal
um until 2015 when playstation got it
and obviously playstation has had it
ever since
and it's a huge game man like it's
literally the best-selling game every
year with a few exceptions
but yeah and i still believe
the game being every two years in the
future would definitely benefit the
titles
and um i i just believe that xbox is
going to do a lot of great things with
activism blizzard as a whole
and yeah i'm looking forward to the
future see what new ips they make see
what old games they bring back i would
love a true crime remake or remaster or
whatever no we make you know any of
these old these other games out there in
the past so yeah i'm definitely looking
forward to the future i don't think the
next team
you know i want a lot of stuff returned
i don't think they're gonna mess with
that stuff too much anymore because yeah
probably not i feel like gta is just
such a juggernaut that people
even though they never do anything with
that franchise
it's like decades before they do
anything with that franchise i feel like
they're so scared
that gta gonna pop in and just steal
everyone's lunch money
yeah yeah
the six is gonna be huge speaking of
this
like yeah you know what about that uh
yeah i got that remaster of
bro was the red dead one and max payne
yeah they gonna do that because you guys
about to about yeah defend of addition
even though those weren't weren't good
but yeah it's up about that so we just
gotta we're just gonna skip all this
we're gonna go to gta 6. i think it's
this i thought y'all have been working
on six
yeah it was really one or something else
no i thought the remedy was doing max
payne one and two remake
yeah
it was something that was red dead one
and something else i can't remember
but yeah you're right they was like nah
we just don't focus on gta 6.
five people working on gta 6 in the
basement
[Laughter]
yeah they try to like knock on the door
to come out and get water and they're
like go back down there
don't come down that level's done
i'm not sure if this game's still in the
top 10 uh gta 5 in cells but let me tell
you man when we get into six
oh boy gta 4 was supposed to be a remake
they said of four it was rare yeah the
dj4 yep thanks infernal games i would
have taken four for sure gta 4 was good
but
gta 6 is going to be ridiculous in terms
of how they
really bring that world back that gta
online because it's going to be so much
i can't tell you how many people i knows
like who spent over 5 000 on that game
just buying the yachts and stuff like
that like i'm
crazy killing i gotta have this i need
daily i gotta have that yacht i'm like
it ain't even you know i mean like it's
not something you could drive around
it'll be different you could drive it
around but no you're buying a yacht that
you teleport to you're stationed and you
can't do anything what aside from just
reenact something
but you know we're basically i gotta be
honest man these games somehow
i don't know if they brainwash us to
okay like 2k right nba 2k
i remember going into the park or the
city right
and
when you walk around with that doodle
brown shirt on
you feel like bro i you know it feels
like real life like you have to get some
clothes i i told a story on my podcast a
friend of mine we were in in the city it
was his first time being there
so we were in a party with like six
other guys we're playing and they was
roasting them
like oh man look at your gear man you
got the brown shirt oh you got the great
shoes
and he felt obligated he texts me like
dirt
bro what do i have to do to get some
gear right so he he you know i told him
and he
you know spent 20 real dollars in vc and
went to get some clothes because
they do man they do a good job of making
you feel like you have to spend some
money like you said people with the
yachts
you can't even drive it around but they
want it man i know you've seen on
youtube like them couples pranks they'd
be like deleting a micros or whatever
yeah listen when these dudes be like yo
i spent two hundred three hundred
dollars in that account i'd be like yo
hold up like it'd be like that y'all be
sure to have a chat it's serious bro it
is serious man listen
i play 2k a lot i don't play my part my
city that much but it is serious bro i'm
like y'all y'all would think is y'all
being gamers y'all be smart enough to
have a backup download of all your stuff
if you live with someone devious like oh
yeah
i trust my girl for that oh my goodness
all my stuff got locked for a reason
exactly
none of my ass
facts you know i am kind of curious
because i see a lot of people talking
about the god of war stuff
um like
what do you like realistically what do
you think this game's going to like
score metacritic-wise
got a war yeah the ragnarok
i think ragnarok's going to heal 90 for
sure
i'll give you three point uh three point
uh
thing so let's say 91 you know
91 you guys think yeah well like the
first one here with 95 995 yeah i'm
thinking it's gonna hit like a 90
because the reason why it says on the
90s because you know it's it's a
continuation right it's not the flight
the first time we saw a god of war
we're like holy hell it's third person
it looks fantastic it's a different
approach uh that
wow fact is going now it's you know
we're used to it now so now that's the
90s going to come down strictly to the
story how they handle the characters and
just how ambitious they go about it and
since we're already getting kind of
we're getting snippets towards it right
with the uh mjolnir and the collector's
edition say hey something big might
happen in this so you you never know man
something i do hope that is trying to
spoil something i understand
[Music]
you know we might see some weapons in
here maybe maybe tear might give you a
weapon or something
i think you're going to snatch up thor's
hammer i don't know why but i feel like
you're going to use that hammer that'd
be crazy though if it's like cursed like
the mcu he tries to lift it and his arm
comes off actually
i was watching like that's actually not
like the actual uh
north pathology like that's just a
marvel thing that you have to be worthy
and what's funny is i didn't know that
like it's crazy how much mcu has
influenced everything to think it's got
to be like that like an actual
north mythology like thor's fat like
he got weight to him and yeah like
people didn't like the way he was
looking because it wasn't
it wasn't it was a christmas package
yeah it was a chris evans worst figure
they were expecting that and
the funny thing is too i don't know if
you all remember when we first saw thor
and the first one yeah i remember he had
like that cloak on he had like that hood
on it like that he had on that uh
remember it was raining it was
thundering you don't remember like at
the end of the game like before when you
go to the house
and
after you beat after you beat like the
main boss you go to the house and then
you hit that cut scene and you see like
oh and at the end exactly at the end
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah tomorrow
but he's like who are you did he
achieves mjolnir and he's like
okay first of all his design i thought
his design was gonna be that but they
was like nah nah nah nah this dude is
gonna like he's gonna look different i'm
like okay well
i thought that design was fire because
it kept him ambitious you know or
ambiguous like you like what's he look
like who is this guy he's just like
oh [ __ ] it really is
a story like because i didn't know who
it was at first i'm like is that really
thor or could that be odin because a lot
of people talk about it but i'm like
can't be owned because yes i'm just
that's one thing i'm beyond scared of is
how they're going to handle that story
well like that no it's just god of war
ragnarok i've brought it up oh there's
so much variables i just don't
understand how they're gonna
realistically do a story that
it's like the issues that kingdom hearts
three had there were so many variables
up to that point that it i didn't know
how they're to realistically tell that
story and hit every note that needs to
be hit
and i think they might have an issue
with that man i don't know if it's going
to like flop or anything like that
you know i think they might do it people
like well the game is going to be long
oh okay is it gonna be a lot of
cutscenes likes
i feel about odin in past cuz like the
big thing that i've been hearing is that
the game is gonna
take us to egypt
so how would you guys feel with let's
say it's odin and anubis is it the
little girl egyptian
i
think so i'm not sure i didn't look her
up but that'd be crazy i think the game
takes us to egypt and like the god you
know of uh the underworld anubis
teams up with
odin
i actually for some reason i want i i
want the greek mythology to to like mix
back into it i don't know why like i i
want to see the greek mythology is fine
you don't be crazy you know what i know
this would never happen
but
if he's fighting odin he's getting
bodied kratos is like like
and somehow
zeus comes back
ah it helps and helps cradles fight odin
yeah that's a good question
the thing is is
you can set it to where like
flashbacks that showed like the gods
can't stand each other you know what i'm
saying and like zeus was killed before
he could kill
odin
so because you could you could word it
in a way that would make sense where
it's not like them teaming up it's
i hate kratos but i can't stand odin you
know
well here's here's the one variable we
forgot about too and this is uh where i
loved the 2018 so much because they they
hit us with that curveball when we're
when we go to the house because we have
to go to the you know the norse version
of the underworld yeah i remember we had
to get the blades yeah who do we see on
the boat we saw athena and i'm like okay
so they they're i guarantee you there's
some twists for sure
with her and how she goes about it
because it'd be crazy if she
let's say she hypothetically i don't
know miraculously comes back to life or
something you know i mean she kills crap
i don't know how they would do it but
there's just so many things they could
do because the way atres is being built
you know he's now
in the trailer
don't know that it's on site
because part of me feels like when he
was in the underworld in god of war 2018
uh clearly spoiler they brought zeus
in that like
that scene i feel like for a reason i
don't know if it was like just to show
where he came from but it's just like
they did have a lot of greek mythology
like easter eggs in that and it's just
like are they not going to do anything
with that part of zoo of kratos like
part of me feels like something's got to
happen in that greek pathology lane i
don't know if there's people coming back
to life
you know
i mean again we
it's been proven though that's thing too
that norse gods are stronger than the
greek gods so
even if zeus did come back and let's say
he did
try to help kratos he ate
the hole in the game he might have had
another comment
it would probably be one of those things
where they're all three fighting each
other but zeus is fighting more odin
than kratos you know what i'm saying
like craig like kratos is about to kill
him and you just see zeus pop up like
grab a shirt and throw him he's like if
anyone's killed it's me
like that's why i say you just make it
like you make it like
cray like zeus hates kratos
but odin has been like there's been
hates for
decades generations you know what i'm
saying
uh but you know we're gonna go ahead and
uh wrap this up uh you know it was a
good show man we had a pretty good uh
turnout had 270 people in here you know
appreciate you guys coming in week for a
week especially this dry
ass month it's definitely dry i want to
do and do a video and then to talk about
right the discord thing the discord
thing you could talk about i don't want
to talk about it
no no like not a whole video
we can't we can't be you at we can't
talk about a future
but you know i appreciate it for coming
through you know we uh this has been a
very you know we've we usually have
pretty dry julys but this has been
really dry like this has been the worst
july of making content i've ever
experienced like
two weeks we had to wing it
like we get winged and i'm sure you've
you you dirt and cloud a bit cloud i'm
sure you've noticed like when we do
these shows
it's us that makes these shows
entertaining because the news they're
entertaining like at all the news is
very dry right now there ain't nothing
to talk about it's picking up a little
bit just a little bit but you know
that's why i personally want the
activision deal to finally finish
because yeah that'd be something i feel
like the reason microsoft's very quiet
on a lot of stuff
is because they don't want
to
have any hiccups with that activision do
but you know uh i it's like i said i
appreciate you guys from coming out i've
been trying this thing with with uh with
that with
youtube they have like a restream
feature now
it's kind of like um
uh
what's
on on twitch but i don't know how it
works every time i try to do it it
doesn't work
uh i put like the channel uh that you
want to read or whatever and they got to
be live i think that's how it works well
you see but i tried that
on iop and it didn't work
so i don't know how it works you know
maybe someone in the chat can tell me uh
maybe some of you
someone they're going crazy in that chat
uh atreyus is the father of the world
separate uh serpent well that's actually
true
jesus death was warranted look i'm not
trying to say bring zeus back i just
think it would be cool to have those
twists yeah just to see something
that you know would be even crazier if
like all the gods
came back from uh from greek pathology
and they're like at war with uh north
mythology for some reason like obviously
none of that shit's happening but i just
want such you see hercules pop up with
no face
right
hey let me tell you something god of war
three man oh my god bro
that was one of the most gangster things
i've ever seen ever bro dude when this
man legit said okay you took my weapons
i'm going to triumph and you left the
entire damn arena and you're like
okay like this man was not playing i'm
going to win this day of battle and he
got end up
costing him his face
and i think that's when it comes to god
of war that's what's missing
from god of war is that
is that
the extra oof you know i i don't feel
like god awards had it for years like
this 2018 god of war 3
is probably
addict wants a rumble royale
yeah
about that uh somebody tried to argue
with me i'm blaze about that it was like
god of war 2018 is the most glorious god
of war oh man like that person must
didn't play three you have not played
god of war three
that's why i like i love god of war 2018
but i'm sorry it doesn't even know how
to handle the three yeah
think about three in a matter of like 30
minutes
you you kill poseidon
yeah like poseidon and that fight is
insane like you're literally still looks
good still looks good and that that's
why like i get annoyed when people act
like there's no emotion in god of war uh
three two and one because it's like
there's literally a scene where you have
to protect your wife and kid in a
different dimension and the only way to
protect the way to give them health is
to take health from you
like it's just like that that game is so
deep and like i get it they had to
reimagine it they had to really push uh
you know god of war forward but you
can't tell me three isn't the best god
of war by far that's one of the most
gangster games ever man
was so fired bro that's the first game
just i was the pinnacle for for the
franchise for me that was it that was
the
chef's kiss just that's the one to go
yeah that might be one of the best games
like sony's ever made like for real like
just just think about the fights that
was in that game like cradles just think
about the the transition between two to
three kratos literally brought all the
titans and said you wanted some smoke i
got some smoke that's how the game
started off bro that's how the game
started oh that's so memorable yeah all
the titans climbing the mount olympus
and then you think okay i'm about to
fight zeus this man hits you with the
biggest
lightning bolt he could muster and he
sends you to hell i'm like
okay that was it that was the opening
and it's like the game was fire bro it
just so it's so damn good and
you know what i would say about 2018
that you know what i see my balder
obviously you know how the game starts
to a ball there uh
i will give the game this because we're
the game did catch me off guard they
caught us off all off guard like when
craig was showing this off but he's
getting punched he's like
leave and then this man just
showed you because this man it's a damn
all the way over here he's like
okay like i was not expecting that then
it just turned into some damn it was
like a damn goku fight because yeah yeah
it was dope though
though they had some crazy moments but
it's just like out or three though man
like like who was the guy that he took
his uh would they take his feet or shoes
i don't remember oh uh um
cut his greaves off
the one that flew he you were fighting
falling down that giant hill and he
ripped your wings off
yeah the uh the head like that was the
flashlight man that was the gangster
and that's why like i can't get down on
the story of 18 was better like the
story of two was amazing like literally
you go through you kill ares in god of
war one and you're like the re they
didn't touch ares because he was a god
they like look we don't interfere with
stuff like that like we can't do that
and aries was doing some really
like mean stuff in one
yeah but zeus was like yo kratos being
too much
yeah he's like he's like he's an aries
out loud out loud
and then you just see how i love how
they tied hercules uh further into three
because hercules is like oh why you were
being crowned the god of war i was sent
to fetch an apple
i was sent to kill the demon light i'm
like well to be honest i mean he gave
you some dope gear for killing the lion
but no he's like no i want to be god
awards like okay but the moment that
will always dude the moment that will
always stand
to me is one of the most like standout
moments of that game is when you're
fighting chronos and this man has you
like this
and you can he can't crush you because
you're strong you're pushing this man
back he's trying to crush you that
moment so it's like
okay
where is that in 2018 that was one of
the most impressive things i've ever
seen at that time bro
like the size of that guy ripping his
nails off and off yeah technical all the
god awards are masterpiece man oh yes
what about ascension
it said it was good
i'm not saying it was amazing i didn't
finish ascension for some reason though
but like to think what i like about it
is just like they always
they always went beyond
beyond every game like you know you sit
there you think you have a good story
kratos and zeus show up and zeus is
pretty much like you're doing too much
and kills you with that sword yeah like
then you you you come out
and i think you you escape hell
and then you get sit there again in
three you like yeah yeah it's just like
it's such a good game and that's why i
get so annoyed when people put so much
of a go on 18 18 is amazing but i'm
sorry he's amazing i think 18 doesn't
beat two or three like they might beat
one but it's one thing that i remember
about eight out of 18 and i mean cut you
off but the thing that it just we all
remember because it was like the only
challenging part about the game was the
valkyries the main thing we talked about
is valkyries in 2018. yeah when you go
into god award you know three for
example
everybody remembers your fight with damn
hades hades was a dope fight
you know there's a lot of stuff
memorable you know you fighting him in
his own dimension that you take his soul
was like
come on where's the only the only
memorable fight is the first and the
last and the dragon in in 18 like
like i you know fighting aries was was
better than those fights to a lot of
degree like
it it's just like look like you know i
get it you know we're going to go and
end this because we definitely went way
off track
i don't know like i i just get annoyed
when the god of war stuff comes up and
people don't want to give three it's
it's flowers like oh three it was fire
bro the three words
three had one the doping soundtracks
which just like a rage
that sounds
like you guys know that
but god of war is one of my favorite
franchises actually i was glad i was
able to get a ps5 this summer because i
assumed it was coming out this year and
i wanted to have a ps5 before ragnarok
come out hey yo griggity you know you
got goosebumps when when you see his
face right and they fire he throws
display but then when you hit start
screen he goes my vengeance it's fire
bro oh god i just yeah util you know we
we might we might joke about good ol uh
david jaffee a lot man we we we might we
might clown on him and joke on him a
little bit
but damn he definitely made he did was
he was he in charge of three
he two and one i regret he oversaw three
as well well he he led the foundation
that made
like without the reason i made three so
fantastic is because there was no cliff
notes it was straight action 24 7.
because
of the foundation they built from one to
two that made three so good because if
they didn't do one and two the way they
did they couldn't have stayed in that
epic i'm gonna beat everyone's ass 24 7.
like literally if you go back and you
look at how the evolution happened in
three kratos was in the smoke 24 7. yeah
yeah kratos was walking around killing
everybody he pop up a new god that not
only does he kill the god he uses the
god's abilities to to kill the next god
yeah right that was man it was so good
man but you know uh
big cloud where can the people find you
i know what you got going on let look
we're gonna end we'll talk about god of
war all damn day where where can people
find you [ __ ]
yeah man it was uh good to be on the
show i appreciate it uh you guys can
find me big cloud gaming youtube twitch
and twitter every friday rgt podcast 5
pm eastern standard time we will be
going to 7 00 p.m eastern standard time
in september but right now we're at 5
p.m so that's where we at on my channel
we go over everything and uh addict's
been on there a few times we had cognito
on a few you know a few times as well
come on through if you want to listen to
the show here's some game and takes and
uh have some fun and then we got a two
dollar super chat from amazing neil good
show fellas appreciate this uh the
support man being very generous there uh
you know and plus you know we got 192
people still rocking with this man hit
that like button let's try to get it to
150 for the end of the show dirt
griggity man what what
you might as well be a panelist at this
point i call you my rotating panelists
[Laughter]
i told you man if i can get here i will
get here
definitely go uh you know i was on his
podcast last night it was definitely you
know what's funny is when you was doing
some of those like integration things
that was happening like you would push a
button and you guys couldn't hear me but
man i was i was dying like i was dying
when you was doing the the the
playstation fanboy crying thing yeah
is that pre-recorded or are you saying
that no that's that's that's me like
like the only thing that's pre-recorded
is the video and the music the little
sad music but all of the voice all the
dialogue that's me live i just kind of
just made my life my little voice you
know it's all fun man it's all fun you
know we have a lot of fun over there
like i said playstation fanboys won't
like my show because we do talk a lot of
trash but it's all all the fun man it's
all in fun
so yeah uh check out uh
like the last episode that as little
addicts said he was a guest on there we
had a good show man it was a lot of fun
you know we um you know we don't take
stuff too serious over there we just
have fun when we talk about gaming we
just you know we just have a good time
over there so check out the last episode
i'm gonna leave it in the chat um
excuse me
yeah so that's about it man
i want to do content i'm gonna try to
find something to talk about
can't find nothing to talk about man
it's it's dry in these streets man it's
extremely dry it's definitely dry bro
but thank you guys for stopping by
yeah so it's like i said uh definitely
go over there and uh
i don't know what's going on uh so
apparently discord's uh uh it's messing
up but anyway
all right so appreciate ever coming
through man you can find me
get uh lord uh iop on twitter you can
find me a
youtube gaming addict i'm probably gonna
start streaming on twitch a lot more
here i know i keep saying that i promise
i'm really gonna do it this time i
promise but anyway i appreciate everyone
for coming through man we it's like i
said we had a great show
it was a pretty entertaining time and
until next time just get me out we're
out of here with uh big cloud
and dirt griggity peace
do a video on the history of zones